james wan vamos a hablar de fútbol
polémica en torno al futbolista pulpo
elba es sin duda alguna raúl el
escándalo en este momento en el fútbol
de francia hablamos de paul pogba hoy
jugador de la juventus y campeón del
mundo en la copa mundo de rusia 2018
este fin de semana su hermano matías
publicó en redes sociales un vídeo en el
que asegura que haría grandes
revelaciones al mundo entero sobre paul
este pool con que esto contestó el
domingo con un comunicado firmado por
sus representantes en el que asegura las
recientes declaraciones de mattia pogba
en redes sociales no son
desafortunadamente una sorpresa éstas se
suman a unas amenazas e intentos de
extorsión en banda organizada contra
paul pogba y es que según medios
franceses paul pogba denuncia que su
hermano le habría reclamado 13 millones
de euros a modo de pago por años de
servicio de acompañamiento y seguridad
al respecto la agencia de fp confirma
que ya la fiscalía de parís se abrió una
investigación preliminar a comienzos de
mes por presunta extorsión en banda
organizada y en toda esta polémica a
matías acusó a poco vaya a ser brujería
y le recomendó a quilín mbappe compañero
de paul pogba en la selección
esté cerca de polo